what's up GQ I'm Zoe Kravitz today I'm
going undercover on the internet
it's actually me
[Music]
okay let's check Twitter Zoe Kravitz was
Mary Jane and into the spider-verse I
was I voiced Mary Jane Chris and Phil
are friends of mine and they called me
up and asked me if I would do the voice
it was such a fun project to be a part
of in the movie is so amazing so yeah
fun little fact I love doing animated
voice over work I would like to do more
um I think it's such an amazing art form
and it's just crazy to see what they can
do now and bring something to life
through through voice it's it's cool
when is Big Little Lies coming back on
quit playing with me I know I don't
think it is we talked about doing a
season three a lot and unfortunately
jean-marc valet our incredible director
passed away this last year which is
heartbreaking and I just can't imagine
going on without him he really was the
Visionary for that show so unfortunately
it's done
next Carrie Bradshaw Zoe as Carrie is
probably my favorite fan cast I thought
of well thanks I mean I'm a huge Sex in
the City fan like huge like I can quote
every episode I mean no one can play
Carrie but Carrie only Carrie can play
Carrie Sarah Jessica Parker you know
that's the Holy Grail but I would you
know I'd play like her friend or
something the new Samantha no just
kidding Samantha I love you okay I'm
admittedly late to getting the chance to
watch this but Zoe Kravitz High Fidelity
remake is goddamn great thank you so
much deserved a second season and also
how many people can say they starred in
a TV reboot of a movie their mom was in
that's true my mother was in the
original film which was one of my
favorite movies growing up and thank you
I thought it was a really good show too
we had a lot of fun making it the cast
was amazing and I think there was a lot
of places for the story and the world to
go but unfortunately Hulu did not agree
and now we are in TV heaven but thanks
for watching posted
Cora Cora what's Cora what does Zoe
Kravitz think of Robert Pattinson as
Batman obviously think he's very good I
think he's great I think he did
incredible work I think that he made the
character his own which is really hard
to do with something that we've seen so
many times before and that we've all
grown up with I think that he brought
Humanity to the character as well which
was really hard to do there are so many
restrictions in terms of
you know kind of being able to emote
when you're wearing that mask you know
you can't really move that much and they
can't really see your face so much and
so it's a big Challenge and I think he
did an amazing job go rob next
is Zoe Kravitz singing in big little
lies yep that's me that's me singing you
know I was pre-recorded so I went to the
studio and and sang the song it was
really fun it was a cool cover we
recorded that scene so many times we did
it so many times over and over again and
because my character was singing in the
background of a lot of other things that
were going on I sang that song like a
hundred times and I think by the end
everybody in the cast and crew including
myself
did not want to hear it anymore so it's
actually really triggering but yeah that
was me singing
how many tattoos does Zoe Kravitz have I
don't know
I've lost count I don't know I got my
first tattoo when I was 18 because my
parents wouldn't let me get one until I
was 18. I've had some removed I get some
put back I mean live just like it's
crazy I have no idea I do think you
should be like 35 before you can get
tattoos because you get them and then
you don't like them anymore I have no
idea I have so many little ones
I feel like it's like in the
30s 40s replied
Tick Tock were the young kids go oh
hello it's a picture of me my dad
wearing matching jackets Family full of
icons thank you I wonder what family
dinner is like
LOL I mean it depends if me and my
father are eating good food together
we're only talking about the food like
my dad likes to give commentary you know
it's like oh the chicken and then the
crispiness and you have to dip it in the
sauce and try it like it's like we just
talk about what we're eating as we're
eating it because we're big Foodies yeah
the LK uh food commentary is legendary
the way Zoe Kravitz gives off tall
energy had me convinced that she was 5
10. what how tall is she okay well thank
you very much I am not 510 I am very
short
I'm five one and a half I am a tiny
person the amount of times that I get
reminded how small I am is often you
know you like go to the airport and
they're like you are so much shorter in
person like thank you for the reminder
petite as my mom would say she doesn't
like the word short she always says
you're petite so I'm petite
posted Wikipedia where nothing is true
Kravitz landed her first film role while
in High School playing a babysitter
hired by Catherine Zeta Jones character
in 2007 romantic comedy No Reservations
that is true that was my first job and I
played a Gothic babysitter when I went
to the audition I went in full goth
makeup which is why I think I got that
part I was committed all I did really
acting you know when I was in school I
was kind of an average student and I was
in drama club and that was always where
I had the most fun and made the most
friends and it was just where I felt
comfortable and I never really thought
about doing it as a career until High
School ended and it was just the only
thing that I had ever really done so I
just kind of kept it going Kravitz a set
to make her directorial debut with [ __ ]
Island which she also co-wrote and
co-produced that is true I directed the
film this summer I'm in post now I'm
editing and it was a very wild ride it's
really
crazy how actors have no idea what it
takes to make a film I've been on
hundreds of film sets and I just now
learned what it takes to make a movie so
it was a great learning experience for
me wish me luck you guys
okay Reddit
so obsessed with Reese Witherspoon's
piece on Zoe Kravitz for the time 100.
it must have been such an incredible
feeling to be chosen yes it was and to
have Reese do the write-up yeah crazy
crazy that I was in the time 100 quite
an honor and to have someone as
incredible as Reese and someone that's
as important to me as Reese writes such
a wonderful touching piece that was
amazing it made me cry when I read it so
thank you Reese I love you it was
amazing working with Reese I had been
I'd met her before and I'd been a fan of
hers and she's so quick and so funny and
so involved you know in front of the
camera behind the camera it was really a
huge inspiration to see a woman like her
be so involved in the business side and
the producing side too so I was really
inspired by that and on a personal note
just Reese has become one of my dearest
friends and someone I can really you
know rely on and turn to she's just a
very important person in my life and I'm
very thankful to to know her how would
you describe Zoe Kravitz's Style I want
to get some new stuff for fall and I
really like the way Zoe dresses how
would you describe it what store should
I try I mean I really try and dress
comfortably it's really important that
you feel comfortable in what you're
wearing because I think that you can
feel and see when someone isn't
comfortable in their clothes and then no
matter how cool looking it is it kind of
strips all that away I also live in New
York so I walk around a lot and I just
think Comfort is really important I like
oversized clothes a lot I wear a lot of
black and I'm really into Basics I
really like jeans and white t-shirts and
like big chunky sweaters but I also just
like to get up and go I don't like to
think about it too much when I wake up
in the morning so
Basics are good
next
Instagram hello old friend
just watch this was empowering as hell
for anxious introverts facing their
fears beautifully done thank you I
really love this film you handled
agoraphobia so well and I loved how
subtle everything was portrayed and shot
well done thank you well Steven
Soderberg the director is obviously a
you know a master so you know that's
part of the reason the movie is so good
I know a lot of people suffer from
social anxiety in general but then after
the pandemic I think that was heightened
for a lot of people I connected to the
character Angela a lot I suffer from
anxiety as well so I know panic attacks
are something I'm quite familiar with so
I was you know able to kind of draw from
my own experience to play the character
this is a picture from our first stamp
[ __ ] Island what directors inspire you
the most obviously I can't think of any
right now because that's what happens
when you're asked a question like that
you know I love Tarantino I love Adrian
line I love Fellini I love so many
directors I just can't think of any
of them but
a huge set of file yeah well I wasn't
allowed I didn't have television when I
was a kid my mom didn't allow me to
watch TV but I was allowed to watch one
movie a weekend and so I would kind of
get obsessed with films I love the Coen
Brothers I love like dark films dark
comedies favorite picture from the
Batman Premiere you must redo breakfast
activities that would be a really hard
thing to redo I just think that when
something is done so iconically and
perfectly it's like why touch it but
thank you that'd be fun in theory I
don't think I have the balls to do that
ooh YouTube okay I know what that is
[Music]
bro bro why do I want to do this voice
bro she is so funny no it's me sorry bro
she is so funny she could be a cast
member on thanks I would love to see her
do more comedy I would love to do more
comedy I had so much fun hosting SNL it
was a dream of mine obviously comedy is
something I have not done a lot of and I
think that could be pretty funny I would
love that so anybody who has any great
comedy scripts or sketch ideas you just
hit me and I'll
come do that
this song just popped up in my head
never watched the video though this is
some great word play and I don't even
listen to Jay like that oh ain't that
Zoe Kravitz yes this is me
in a Jay-Z video called I know I don't
even know when this was shot how many
years ago
2011 olden days yeah olden days yeah I
knew the director of this video
and they asked me to do it why would I
say no it's like me walking around New
York City and stuff I haven't seen it in
a long time either I don't really
remember the premise yeah I mean it was
an honor and a privilege to be in a
Jay-Z video obviously
okay that's it I'm signing off the
internet bye